Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
A veces me pregunto
si de verdad se acabó el amor.
Veo y escucho por todos lados
que las relaciones entre
los géneros están cambiando.
Y en los últimos tiempos, rapidísimo.
Se escucha una consigna que dice:
"se va a caer, se va a caer".
¿Se caerá el patriarcado
y se llevará consigo el amor?
Creo entender que está vivo
y causando mil y un enredos
en las relaciones afectivas.
Y entonces me pregunto,
¿hay posibilidad de reconstruir algo?
¿O el futuro amoroso será inevitablemente
un páramo de soledad y crueldad?
Un pibe me consultó hace poco y me dijo:
"Me mandé un moco
con mi exnovia hace un tiempo
y ella me acaba de escrachar".
No me dijo a qué se refería
con esto de mandarse un moco.
Me lo tuve que imaginar.
Y entonces empecé a pensar.
Empecé a repasar mentalmente.
¿La habrá forzado a tener relaciones
sexuales que ella no quería?
¿Habrá aprovechado en alguna fiesta
que ella estaba fumada o tomada
y la habrá forzado a tener sexo
con otros pibes?
¿Habrá sido violento con ella
para resolver algún conflicto?
¿O simplemente la habrá
dejado plantada sin aviso?
Solo me dice que sabe que
lo que hizo no está bien.
Pero también me dice que lo sabe ahora,
no lo sabía entonces.
Me cuenta que una vez la vio mal
y le preguntó qué le pasaba.
Y ella le explicó.
Y a él le pareció que ella
era un poquito exagerada.
Que no entendía que
"los hombres somos así".
Que tendría que ser
"un poquito más piola y abierta".
Pero eso lo sabe ahora,
no lo sabía entonces.
"¿Sabés lo que me pasaba?
Yo no pensaba en lo que mis conductas
podían causar en las demás personas.
Y mucho menos en las mujeres.
Hacía lo que me pintaba
o lo que me parecía.
Y ahora que sé, quiero saber
'¿hay algo que yo pueda hacer para
mejorar o mi pasado me condena?'"
No me deja de sorprender que por fin
hayamos llegado a un momento histórico
en el cual los varones se empiezan
a cuestionar sus privilegios
y el dolor que los mismos
pueden causar en los demás.
Y hay mucho que se puede hacer con esto.
Él, este pibe, hay mucho que puede
hacer para mejorar la situación.
"Te sugiero que le pidas perdón,
que le escribas,
y le digas que vos ya no sos el que eras,
que cambiaste y hoy sos alguien
al que le importa
el dolor que causa en la otra persona
y trata de evitarlo en lo que puede".
"¿Qué pasa si ella no me contesta
o no le interesa estar
en contacto conmigo?"
"No insistas, aceptá su no.
De esa manera se va a dar cuenta
de que sos sincero".
Y algo va a cambiar en ella y en vos.
Hay algo sanador
en encontrarse con alguien
que puede revisarse a sí mismo.
Y perdonar no implica
recomponer el vínculo.
Solo implica sacarse de adentro
el dolor que implica sostener un rencor.
Por mi trabajo, he hablado con
muchísimas mujeres sobre estos temas.
Y ellas me enseñaron que
están esperando que los varones
pidan perdón por las cosas
que les hicieron.
Que se hagan cargo de sus acciones.
Pero, fundamentalmente,
que no las hagan más.
Y esto pasa mucho, pero que
pase mucho no es que esté bien.
Y los varones no lo hacen
porque sean ni enfermos ni malos.
Sino que lo hacen porque
son hijos sanos del patriarcado.
Y eso tiene remedio.
Es la famosa deconstrucción
de la masculinidad hegemónica.
Así como ningún pibe nace chorro,
ningún pibe nace macho.
(Aplausos)
Eso se aprende.
Y si se aprende, se puede desaprender.
Podemos enseñar a los pibes
desde chiquitos,
desde el jardín, a ser diferentes.
Que ser varón no sea nunca más
poner en riesgo a alguien.
Las mujeres nos hemos ganado,
y ahí lo digo en primera persona,
ser sujetas en paridad
también en el sexo y el amor.
Eso es algo que mi generación
de mujeres deseábamos
pero no creíamos
que íbamos a alcanzar a ver.
Todo esto me dejó pensando
sobre las relaciones entre
los sujetos y el poder.
¿Qué hacemos cuando tenemos
más poder que la otra persona?
Por ejemplo, los padres con los hijos.
Los varones con las mujeres.
Los hijos adultos con los padres viejos.
¿Nos controlamos de
nuestra propia agresividad?
¿O hacemos lo que queremos porque podemos?
¿Qué pasa cuando se da vuelta la tortilla?
Cuando, por ejemplo, yo he sido
una mujer víctima y ya tengo más poder.
O cuando, por ejemplo, crecí
y ya no soy más ni una niña,
ni un niño, ni un niñe, ni une niñe,
¿me como al caníbal y me transformo
en caníbal o tengo otra salida?
Creo que hablar de todos
estos temas nos puede ayudar
a que haya un nuevo diálogo
y ojalá un nuevo guion amoroso
entre los géneros.
La pregunta del millón hoy
es cómo poder recomponer
de manera no autoritaria
y sin nostalgia por el pasado
las relaciones entre los géneros.
¿Podemos construir un modo de amorosidad
que esté muy lejos
de "La bella y la bestia"
y mucho más cerca de las mujeres
y los varones actuales?
Esto que les cuento también pasa
en las adolescencias en los colegios.
En los últimos tiempos ha habido
muchas situaciones de abuso,
muchas denuncias de abuso,
y también acciones autogestivas
de defensa que se llaman escraches.
Todo el año pasado estuve trabajando
en un colegio secundario
porque había muchos problemas.
Las autoridades nos llamaron porque
el clima de hostilidad era altísimo.
Esa escuela se había convertido
en un lugar muy feo para estar
para todo el mundo.
Y nos pidieron que trabajemos
con los grupos problemáticos.
Pero no hicimos eso.
Ofrecimos trabajar con todo el mundo.
¿Por qué? Porque los grupos problemáticos
son solo la punta del iceberg
de un fenómeno muchísimo más extenso
que es el malestar actual de
las relaciones entre los géneros.
Y esto es porque estalló
el orden sexual de la modernidad.
Entonces, trabajamos con todo el mundo.
Trabajamos con el alumnado.
Trabajamos con familias,
trabajamos con docentes.
Trabajamos con autoridades.
Transmitimos nuestra visión del tema.
Pero también escuchamos
lo que tenían para decirnos.
Y así en el diálogo, escuchándonos,
apareció la idea de que había una salida.
Y una idea también muy poderosa
de que escuchándonos todes juntes,
en diferencia, había una esperanza.
Y en ese ida y vuelta, apareció
la creatividad de les pibes.
Ya no eran solo barderos que
había que controlar o vigilar.
Parte de su creatividad
es el consentimiento.
Esto es, preguntar si la otra persona
quiere lo mismo que yo
y aceptar su respuesta.
Hay un mito por ahí
que dice que te la baja.
Pero eso no es verdad.
Es un muy buen invento autogestivo.
Y no lo sacaron de la nada.
Lo sacaron, por ejemplo,
de los protocolos médicos.
De esos que cuando nos hacemos
un estudio firmamos.
O lo que hacemos quienes
investigamos con personas,
que les contamos lo que
vamos a hacer con ellas,
y les pedimos que nos firmen
que están de acuerdo.
Lo sacaron de esos lugares
y lo pusieron a disposición de las
nuevas formas de amar y de desear,
y de tener sexo,
pero sin lastimar y sin abusar.
Elles preguntan personalmente,
por WhatsApp
o por cualquier tipo de aplicación
"¿Da para darse?"
El consentimiento de hoy es como
el preservativo en los años 90
cuando fue la epidemia del HIV.
Entonces, también decían que te la bajaba.
Pero no fue así.
Se inventaron mil tipos de preservativos.
De todos los colores, sabores y texturas.
Slogans como "Póntelo. Pónselo.",
"Usalo, no seas forro",
y mil maneras diferentes
de seguir amando, deseando
y teniendo sexo entonces
con un nuevo amigo, el forro.
El nuevo amigo hoy es el consentimiento.
(Aplausos)
No tiene que ser por formulario triple.
Puede ser juguetón
a la manera de cada quien.
Pero de cualquier modo que sea,
que permita que ambos seamos sujetos.
Que podamos decir no,
y que podamos decir sí.
Y muestra que donde algunos
ven el fin del amor
otros inventan maneras de seguir amando,
deseando y teniendo sexo,
pero incorporando lo nuevo,
que no es otra cosa que algo muy antiguo
que necesita reformularse:
No le hagas al otro lo que
no quieras que te hagan a vos.
(Aplausos)
¿Cómo transformar la crueldad en ternura
en las relaciones entre los géneros?
Si encontramos la respuesta,
esa herramienta la podemos utilizar
para otro tipo de relaciones
donde haya diferencias de poder.
¿Y si resulta que no se acabó el amor
y lo que se acabó es un tipo de amor
y una forma de relacionarse
entre los géneros?
Donde no hay amor, hay crueldad.
Bienvenidas entonces las nuevas
formas de amar y de desear
para que la igualdad y la autonomía
no tengan como contracara
la soledad y la tristeza.
(Aplausos)